joining us now is the aforementioned
congresswoman lauren bobert
congresswoman um i want to get to your
views on this map uh these map freaks on
twitter
but i first want to ask about that
exchange with secretary becerra
uh he believes that this type of surgery
for non-adults
is protecting children
really
laura this is absolutely disgusting and
as you've stated on your show this is uh
not only repulsive but it's child abuse
secretary becerra he is a lawyer he's a
politician he's a bureaucrat and he even
he is making these professions look bad
it is a sad day in america when the
secretary of health and human services
is using his position of influence to
promote
gruesome
gender reassignment surgeries on
children now we know that his record is
not very good
it's actually pretty pathetic on
protecting children and parental rights
so when he came into our committee i
asked him about those things i asked him
if our tax dollars were going to these
um these surgical gender reassignments
on children these gruesome gender
reassignments he had no answer i asked
him if
parents who don't agree with this gender
affirming care and don't want to
mutilate their children if they are at
risk if they are in danger of having
their children removed from their home
he didn't have an answer for that either
i even asked him if men can get pregnant
simple as that and he danced around that
question laura so i had many questions
for him that i asked him on that day and
and we're seeing that they are doing
anything in their power to protect these
people who want to sexualize and groom
our children and now to hear on your
show tonight um that we have these minor
attracted persons what is this world
coming to you know five years ago if you
would have said that this is where all
of this is leading we would have been
called crazy and here we are uh you have
somebody saying that pedophilia that
that's too degrading to call it so we're
going to call it maps what in the world
is happening in america what makes it
sound start talking about this and and
get it right um you know and and really
it's it's not something comfortable to
talk about it's not comfortable
conversations have because we shouldn't
be talking about these things laura
you know this isn't pleasant but we need
to know if our tax dollars are going to
remove the breasts of young girls if our
tax dollars are going to remove the
genitalia of young boys these are
children and my message to the biden
regime
is
get out of our lives get out of our
homes these are our ch
these are our children well they call
this conspiracy you know what they're
saying in response congresswoman they're
saying
you and others probably myself that
we're spouting conspiracy theories
because we're actually quoting
these people whether it's on twitter or
whether we're talking about the
inability to define a mother and they're
called birthing persons now so as not to
offend a radical fringe those are facts
they don't want to actually speak in
terms of facts they want to just throw
out pejoratives like oh it's a
conspiracy theory like the hunter biden
laptop was a conspiracy theory i'm going
to get to that next segment
that's exactly right laura anytime they
don't like the facts that are coming out
they call it a conspiracy uh we have
been putting out information all along
we're called names we're called
conspiracy theorists we're called
racists we're called bigots just for not
going along with their agenda they even
turn on their own whenever they aren't
uh falling in line with their agenda and
you know i i totally believe that
secretary becerra needs to be removed
from his position uh i am willing to
call on him to be removed um
for what he is doing to promote um this
mutilation of children in america uh
this is absolutely disgusting what's
coming out of his department and and not
only that but look at what's going on at
our southern border and removing title
title 42 right before these summer
months when they know that there's going
to be a surge we're expecting this is
all part of the plan just by november it
truly is too complicated we got to go
congress on about our country this is
everything is being turned upside down
this is it's not this is people don't
understand this isn't a
this isn't some kind of weird like
coincidence this is this is all
happening for a reason okay this is
their policy okay congrat congresswoman
we appreciate you joining us thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else